we wash dishes this is our dish thing is
that this container work it out our
clothes we have washing clothes Survivor
mode you come to use the bathroom will
use it we have a bucket going to get
full take our school per scoop out
whenever we have done this for put in a
bit and hey you go
we have our back we've been doing it
ever since station our water
[Music]
talk about inequality
it all starts if people turn off your
water
one thing is beyond debate is that
people cannot live without water to know
in my city that our governance could
allow human beings in 2014 that they had
water we're facing hard decisions if we
don't get our fiscal house in order if
you look at the situation and detroit
and flint michigan that is not America
that's not civilization we should not be
a country that allows breed and allows
money two separate people for being able
to flush toilets
let's be very careful about making a
doctrinaire statement about whether or
not water is a human right because it
may well be but how do you pay for it